going these in value you guys gotta move
them I got them on Craigslist so just
like do this hey Chris you hoes ain't
never heard of stub up these are for
sure faith get out of my line
go how old are y'all anyway I can't tell
cuz the outfits aren't matching the
faces next I'm sorry dude I'm a-gonna
eating yet no you're not Craig this is
the most legitimate business okay the
last thing we use that we clean that
dude's apartment in our underwear okay
okay hey I bet know I know that we can
find some silly ass way in here okay
okay we gotta do this before the moly
kicks in
yeah
I'm feeling something you know it is
upon us
[Music]
okay we get up there if we can we crawl
inside we're seeing is that the venue
were done
oh my god you I have a Swiss Army knife
it can unscrew the screws okay
I know exactly how we get up there you
get on my shoulders you do the thing you
pry it up and you crawl inside oh my
gosh once I'm inside I'm like take my
clothes off and all the time all in a
rope okay in a knot and I'll pull you up
I'm actually in hot anyway so this works
out this is happening you're such a tea
incredible yeah okay if we're gonna put
one arm you know what feel like you you
Wow yeah if my passion I get fun but
yeah oh yeah yeah and then yeah dude you
every lilz there are besides weeny
little dick people do keep it grounded
you fall a little woozy bear good bear
like we just like a string oh oh my god
I was a rapper my name would be in it go
oh my god ID baby Lou little two ply
milled number oh oh oh you didn't hear
oh my ID new litter stayed light oh my
god
mmm whispering you so dope I forgot he
sounds different right
I love I don't necessarily love you know
to me but I'm an unconditional right or
die for you and I'm grateful for what we
went through to get here meet you
meets you oh my god dude oh my goodness
now I have such a great idea dude
reposition okay it sounds it sounds like
we're like over the phone for the
audience right okay what if we knock
down do would the drugs on this gonna be
like a duel town we could sweat down
onto the audience for some skulls dude
or this page like we try to undo this
stage really yes really yes yeah or we
could go back to the alley that we were
hanging out and just not being that
event yeah we got our own one low Weezy
concert right here yes dude
dude can I tell you something any
benefits anything dude I don't know if I
Know Who I am without you I don't have
the same sense of self I thought I did
dude my ambitions terrified I'm like do
I even like it know how to make new
friends I'm like do I even like people
even I don't even know you know that's
my damn problem dog
I worry in retrospect that I've been
co-opted in your time and keeping me
from you know dude I feel like I've been
relying on you for like my confidence
like I didn't even know my ass was
doping so you taught me it was it's like
you know just like he gave him people
fish you know use your bellies their ass
and then it never go hungry you're not
have any never go go poof that ass
though damn girl bitch you know
what I need to make like meaning of my
own you know as an individual rather
than tag lol remember Jeremy yes
everything on the entity that is us I
want to be like you in a relationship
like like we have but someone who I have
sex with you mean like I cuddle with in
Lincoln really a fourth true and real
shot because I always made you my
priority and you know no I think these
knows what's gonna keep getting is every
time I think of us apart so it's really
like a psychosomatic response to work
crippling good business I mean maybe I
don't know dude oh my god dude we are
codependent we you me we're little Cody
dude that's our DJ name you know and
this space is gonna give us the chance
to be our better bolder cell folder
[Laughter]
sucks
but also it doesn't it's gonna be great
yeah dude it's gonna be great it's gonna
be like so good for so long
[Music]